let's get to the news we got the story
from dailymail.com.uk maxine waters
may have handed defense grounds for
appeal
and the turning over of this trial
derrick chauvin trial judge blasts a
poor
democrat for calling for riots if no
conviction
they say derek chopin's defense attorney
eric nelson called for a mistrial
after the jury retired on monday he
cited rep maxine waters comments on the
case
as he argued there was no way the jury
could be unbiased given constant media
coverage he's right
now that we have u.s representatives
threatening acts of violence in
retaliation to this trial it's frankly
mind-blowing nelson said
judge peter cahill replied i grant you
congresswoman waters may have handed you
grounds for appeal
and the turning over of this trial but
cahill refused to grant a mistrial
and adjourned the court until the jury
comes back with a verdict it wasn't just
that
the defense argued prosecutorial
misconduct
because in rebuttal the prosecution said
that i guess they were like making their
they were telling stories
and it was nonsense and repeatedly kept
saying
that it was essentially fabrication of
facts which you're not allowed to do
in court the prosecution's supposed to
say that you know our expert testified
to this and we hold this to be correct
you can't say the other person's making
making up crap and they're lying and
telling stories
and so when the defense said you know
objection the judge said overruled
don't say stories again but you know
he's allowed to say stories that when
the prosecution kept berating the
defense and insulting them the judge
finally stepped down like okay you got
to stop doing that
this is what bugs me we just saw how
long were the riots going on this so far
in
minneapolis
you guys look they've been uh since were
the recent ones since
last sunday the death of dante wright so
about about eight days yeah a week
nelson immediately the defense for for
chauvin asked the judge to sequester the
jury
and he said so they don't watch the news
they don't see what's going on and the
judge said well
i'll instruct the jury not to watch the
news and the defense argued
everyone knows about what's going on
everyone's talking about it
and he was saying that even tv shows
fictional tv shows on thursday night nbc
or whatever
are referencing the trial and making
statements about what they want to occur
and so he's like you need to sequester
then the judge initially said no
then after the riots started with dante
wright then he was like judge i'd like
to ask you again it's a question to the
jury that just like i don't think we
need to do that
and now the judge is like well the jury
the trial may be completely overturned
that's incompetent what does that mean
overturn is that a mistrial so
it means there'll be a verdict then the
defense is
let's say that the jurors come back and
say guilty on all counts
i mean let's say the jury comes back and
says acquitted on all counts but
manslaughter
no matter what happens now the defense
can file an appeal to a higher court
saying
rep maxine waters democrat came
from california came to our state and
said unless we get
a conviction for premeditated murder
which they didn't charge chauvin with
we're going to get more confrontational
they've already been rioting what does
more confrontational mean
what yamiche is that her name
yamiche alcindor said the right is
claiming that
maxine waters called for violence
because she said get more active and
more confrontational
that's not a call for violence and i'm
like
confrontational what does that mean like
confronting somebody
if you're already burning down their
buildings and throwing bricks at cops
what is more confrontational than that
now the judge is admitting yep there it
is the jury the jury of course knows
they've been threatened and they're
going to burn the city down no matter
what
because she said first degree murder and
they don't have that yeah they don't and
then and i thought at minimum they would
at least sequester before the
the weekend started they didn't they
didn't even do that and that's obviously
when when maxine waters
came in i mean i think just being on the
ground um one of our reporters lisa
bennett
she did a great video where she asked
folks hey you know what happens if you
don't get
you know if you guys don't get murdered
and people really say and that are from
brooklyn
i said we're burning it down we're
burning down everybody and they don't
need
um i would say uh you know with maxine
waters comments it's like just you're
just giving these people
more power to just say hey if we do this
we're good to go and i think a lot of
those folks are going to point to last
time and say hey we go out and
you know do our thing it's okay because
kamala harris was there to bail us out
just like last year
and i think that's something that we uh
have to keep up back in our mind
i think all the cops should resign i
think every single cop in in the
minneapolis area should just resign
right now just get out of there just
leave
oh that's tough they voted for it that
they did um
and i know right now the the big
difference right now is compared to last
year is
um you know being on the ground is i
guess minnesota with the law enforcement
they didn't have a communication system
between you know the minnesota state
troopers national guard and then local
police so coming this this year around
being on the ground reporting we learned
that now minnesota has created a program
called operation safety net so now we
have the national guard
local police and state troopers now
working all basically now hand in hand
to control these groups i will say this
i think you know richard you know being
on the ground again in brooklyn center
they did a great job of protecting the
police department you know they put the
barricades they had the law enforcement
there
but one thing that we we have to
remember and i try to tell these folks
all the time is
when you have so much law enforcement
you know concentrate on just one area
it leaves the rest of the city stretched
in i mean just and i i said this last
uh this was reported yesterday but
numbers might even be higher but since
last sunday of dante wright's death
the police department in brooklyn center
which is a little small town area they
have
already received over 200 calls of
either businesses damaged
looted or burglaries and that's one
thing that we have to remember is when
you have so much protection at the
police center
the rest of the city that whole shopping
mall is literally right next to the
police station like
that whole shopping mall that was looted
on the first couple of nights it's
like a hundred yards from this whole
police station this is why i'm saying
the cops should resign or or the very
least you know we had uh uh i think it
was tom rogan he mentioned
they should give notice that in 30 days
they'll all resign that'd be interesting
i've been speaking to some inside
sources inside the
portland pd from last summer and when i
was speaking to a police officer she
said the morale
is low she says we have people
transferring you know you know just
don't say retir yeah return retiring
early
and i mean i i would expect that we see
the same thing here and i know that um
we were speaking about this before the
show tim but the minnesota uh senate
just approved
nine million dollars to get out of state
law enforcement
to help out you know with this upcoming
week so
you know pray for these guys because
yeah they they take a lot of beating
when they're out there
there are low i i've heard from a lot of
people in the comments they're like tim
these cops who are staying are doing it
because they know there are good people
who need to be protected
you know the way i described it was your
house is on fire
we repeatedly tried we tried fighting
the fire last year
but a bunch of people in the house voted
for the arsonists kamala harris was
bailing these people out
soliciting funds joe biden whose staff
is funding the bailouts
and i'm like so at that point it made
sense to be like stay and fight
figuratively have you know show people
what this means and then vote for
somebody who will defend you
and they went democrat they voted for
the people who are defending the rioters
not the cops
so now you got a problem now your house
is burning down and the people you think
you're helping are screaming at you to
get out while the house burns down
around them so i understand the analogy
where it's like we gotta help the people
here who are good and i'm like
i get that but at a certain point don't
you say like the people like imagine a
firefighter goes in a burning house
and he's like i'm gonna get you out of
here ma'am and then she like just grabs
on and squeezes
a flaming beam as high as you can like
no i'm staying the firefighter's got to
get out
before he gets you know engulfed in the
flames uh look
the people who are there who are good
people what are they doing to defend
these cops
do we see press conferences held by
community leaders and activists and
neighborhood watches saying
we support our cops and we need them to
protect us no but what do we see
we see endless riots in support of
shutting down and abolishing the police
so so at a certain point the police need
to send a message
if you're not getting the support nobody
wants you there they voted for the
people who hate you
then you need to say okay then i'll pass
it off to you
and then see what happens you know the
metaphor i'm thinking of is that
10 guilty people go free before one
innocent person suffers and i think that
these people that aren't speaking up
are the innocent bystanders that i don't
want them to suffer that's
that's a different analogy but it
doesn't work i'm not sure if you guys
seen the news too is one of the city
council members from brooklyn center
came out and said hey
you know i get the emotions of heart but
we should wait for due process guff art
so that was the city manager and then a
councilwoman for brooklyn center
admitted
she voted to have him fired because she
was scared they would come after her
all right personal responsibility takes
precedent at a certain point
if you would fire a city manager who
called for due process
because you know this cop shot this guy
and then publicly say i'm scared they'll
attack me
okay you need to either stand up for
what you believe in
or don't come to me for help when you
when you
vote to support these lunatics
look at a certain point you got to throw
water on the fire too but what i think
it is tim from from being on the ground
because
and i think richie could attest to this
is we spoke to a lot of residents who
don't support
obviously the constant clashes in their
neighborhood the destruction the only
thing is
they're they're actually afraid just to
even go on camera interview because they
feel like
if i go on camera with you they'll
destroy myself tomorrow well
i think there is a lot of community
people that do want to stand up they
want to speak out
i think they're just super afraid of the
retaliation exactly because if they feel
like the media the culture
everyone is against since trump since
trump left i mean
very much like during you know the last
year
a lot of the riots have been like us
versus the federal government a la
donald trump no trump no kkk no racist
usa but now that biden's president
it's the system itself and so you're
right
like the the protesters on the ground i
think the ideology has shifted even
even further left because basically now
it's like okay now you really adopt our
plan or else you're a fascist as well so
biden's a fascist
if you know he doesn't adopt abolish the
police effect look i get messages from
people all the time where they're like
i got my family out of minnesota last
week or i'm moving next month or i'm
trying to move out now
i get messages from people say i moved
out six months ago i got i've got
messages from people where they were
like man tim i'm glad you you said to
get out of the city because i got up
before the latest riot started and i
lived real close
so listen i i hear what you're saying by
people scared to go on camera
the founding fathers many of them who
signed the declaration of independence
were killed had their homes burned down
their families were killed they risked
everything to stand up what they
believed in
at a certain point you don't get to be a
pampered golden age american who can sit
in your home and just kick your feet
back and say i'll keep my head down and
be fine
because they are it is expanding it is
getting worse there are a lot of pundits
saying they think the riots after the
chauvin trial gonna be worse than we saw
last year
it's one thing to see the anger over the
death of george floyd
it's another thing to see the state say
he didn't do anything wrong depending on
what the result may be
so maxine waters wants a charge that
didn't actually happen
first degree murder premeditation so
based on her own logic riots are coming
if at this point the people are
unwilling to stand up and defend
themselves
okay well do you expect the like the the
people who are
who are who are speaking up not even
from your area
who are speaking out and risking their
careers who are getting canceled losing
their jobs for defending
you know the the what's what's true and
what's correct
you expect them to come to your aid when
you won't do it yourself
there's that famous line about a leader
who says i would never instruct one of
my men to do something i wouldn't do
myself or one of my
you know men or women yet here you have
people who won't stand up for themselves
asking you to do it for them
and so their cops were like i will i'm
like nah at a certain point
if you're a cop and they're all turning
their back on you refusing to stand up
and even say the words i support you
then you don't have support from them no
matter what they think no matter what
they're telling people
they're lying somebody who truly
supported you would stand up
hold the press conference we support the
police and we reject this
they won't do it why because they're
scared of the extremists
and they aren't willing to fight back in
a figurative sense in any capacity
so at a certain point the cops got to be
like then you're on your own
because what happens kim potter a
26-year veteran
there's a guy wanted for aggravated
robbery dante right
he's resisting arrest he's wanted on a
gun charge so they know he's likely
armed i believe he had a 45 ruger
jumps into his car and she doesn't know
what he's what's going on
and she draws her weapon presumably the
story is she thought it was her taser
she shoots him
this is a tragedy but when you have a
guy wanted for an aggravated robber
that's like robbering someone with a
deadly weapon
and then he jumps in his car you're like
okay
he's he's resisted and he made his act
it's active aggression
should she then defend herself or defend
others
well she said she made a mistake for
that the prosecutor comes out what he
came out during the riots i guess and
said
we are going to do everything in our
power to see her
held accountable through this system
okay she deserves it
she absolutely deserves whatever the
system throws at her because all of
these cops have been watching
what the feckless pathetic spineless
people of their community have been
doing
selling them out sacrificing them to the
mob
and they thought they'd be safe they
thought the mob would ignore them
they thought they could stand there as a
part of the system propping up
injustice and they would be safe nah not
anymore
you you helped prop up a bunch of
arsonists burning down your community
and now you're mad that you're caught in
the fire i'm not i can't run into a
burning building you chose to be
i don't like this metaphor because the
people of the united states are are
sucking off the teat of the federal
reserve bankrupting the world and we
don't deserve to die and be
burning this is totally you're punishing
people for something they're not
necessarily responsible for we're
ignorant of the federal reserve has
nothing to do with it it's the people of
the united states
are spearheading the global catastrophe
financially
you got to get back on subject you're
talking about the people of the city
being responsible because they're not
saying anything no because they voted
for someone
some of them but not all of them the
majority of the state voted for the
people who support the riots and they
still doesn't
but there's and they won't speak there's
a huge number of people that didn't and
even
they don't deserve to be silenced
well is that the no no no are they the
reason i think the reason they're not is
because they're not organized and if one
of them sticks their head up it is gonna
get they
won't even say the words i don't know
man they won't speak up to save their
own lives
then you get no sympathy from me you
have the option to simply stand up and
say
hello good journalist jorge i wish the
police had more support they won't even
do that they're scared
well i'm sorry man life is not always
candy canes and rainbows
and when violent terrorists come to burn
down your neighborhood you at least have
to say please stop
at the at the bare minimum say officer
please help us
they won't even do that so if you've got
terrorists burning down your city
and you don't have the ability to at
least say help
sorry yeah but like jorge was saying if
they get on camera and they say help
their business is going to get destroyed
the next all that is required for evil
to succeed is that good people do
nothing yeah but
or good people put themselves out there
vulnerably that also helps evil succeed
you think how does that make sense
because they get killed easy people need
to stand up and at least do something
instead of nothing
you're saying they got to organize they
might risk themselves well it starts by
speaking
well but not not randomly and
incoherently who's that who said
anything about random and income not
like one random person to get up and be
like
i'm gonna make i'm gonna be the guy that
makes a stand and gets my birth if they
if they formed
underground like the founding fathers
did you brought the founding fathers as
a metaphor
your argument is absurd no they they
organized they
and say king george i hereby declare
you're an idiot
because they would have been executed on
the spot no they had to organize
underground
for for maybe a certain period but they
literally had constitutional conventions
in their states and sent delegates yeah
and they voted on these things right but
it was all under these people are paying
for the police
they're paying for the government
they're paying the politicians and
voting for them
and i'll tell you this the people who
voted for it why would i argue they
don't want it
if somebody was in minneapolis and said
i want joe biden whose staff members
support the rights and i want kamalaris
who supports the rioters
and then the writers come to burn down
their house i can only assume they're
going yes
i voted for this i'm happy it's
happening why would you assume they made
that mistake i don't know what was in
there was in their mind
it's like that guy in los angeles when
the riots were in downtown l.a or
whatever and he was cheering this is
awesome yeah burn it down
and then when they came with him when
they're in a block of his house he goes
no stop don't come to my house
do you think it's that or do you think
people were misled by the portrayal of
what was been going
what what has been going on for the
first year perhaps if they knew
you know the full extent of what has
been happening personal responsibility
too many americans for too long have
been fat and lazy figuratively and
literally
sitting around not paying attention
thinking everything would be done for
them
and i'll put it this way firefighters
risking their lives
because the da's won't prosecute these
people you want to get mad at cops okay
why should a firefighter risk his life
running into literal burning buildings
that are collapsing
because when the police make arrests the
d.a cuts them loose
you want to support your community you
need to speak up and do it but if people
are sitting back saying someone will do
it for me
eventually your house falls down because
you're not maintaining it i cannot
you guys cannot and the police cannot be
the people who are
begging just carry your own weight dude
for once
they won't do it they won't so they vote
for it
and it's i'll tell you this ignorance is
no excuse for supporting tyranny
i i understand the media manipulates i
hate him for it i understand that
these these extremists are terrorizing
and threatening them
but if you don't stand up and just at
least try and no one does
this is here anyway this is the why i
brought up the federal reserve and the
u.s people
ignorance is no excuse for supporting
tyranny we live in the empire
so being ignorant of that is not an
excuse to support that that's correct
that's my point
you're right but i don't want to punish
and destroy everyone you know who's
who's you you mean you wouldn't join
anti-fuzz what you're saying well i just
i i have this stupid sympathy for those
ignorant people
i don't want to see them suffer
no one does well you're making the
argument that you want the police to
leave so
i'm sorry richie what what what breeds
that ignorance like why aren't people
aware of that
we live in a medium society wealth
we we for too long have been people in
good
times breeding weak individuals weak
citizens
who don't care about civic duty or
responsibility and i'm not talking about
some nationalistic whatever i'm talking
about literally being like
going and giving your firefighters some
brownies and being like thank you for
everything you do
or going your cops and talking to them
about issues you're concerned about
you've heard about in the media they
don't even do that
they don't even they don't even do that
it's just media manipulation
political sectarianism and a bunch of
lazy disinterested people who are like
i'm keep my head down cause i got it
good okay listen
there was a period in in ours in our
in our country in our nation's history
where death was like
you died you know i mean look at these
stories from back in like the old
pioneer days in the wild west people
understood risk
and responsibility and they had to wake
up at six in the morning and farm and go
to bed at 11 at night and it was work
work work all day every day
now we have all of the comforts of the
first world we have fast food mcdonald's
we get
we we have too much food americans are
gaining weight like crazy and they're
doing less work and they're
now you have a whole section of a sect
of people who are leftists who think
they shouldn't have to do work at all
we are just becoming as a as a country
we we reject responsibility for our own
lives and our own selves and we say the
police will do it
and then when the police can't do it
they're overrun well i'm not gonna speak
up someone else have to do it okay well
then
listen man if a fire is raging towards
your home and you're like i'm not gonna
put out a firefight i'll get here
okay well eventually your house burns
down that's not me saying i want your
house burned i don't want your house to
burn down
but it's also me saying i don't want my
firefighters to die because you refused
to start
turning your hose on the very least you
could have done that right
and and and wet your house down now your
house is a raging five alarm fire and
the firefighters one's gonna die because
of you that's why i'm saying the police
need to back out
before things but before look i'll tell
you what's gonna happen
the cops stick around we get a kim
potter situation if the cops
right off the bat said we won't stand
for this well then kim potter wouldn't
have been there to create another
circumstance that they use
to light the country on fire i'm not
saying i know the solution is but i can
tell you this
it's a chinese finger trap and the cops
keep pulling and you're not going to get
out of it you keep doing this
the people around you won't support you
so something needs to change and it's
changed now so people realize what's
happening
even when the cops are there i mean
kenosha there were no firefighters and
no cops like in the situation where they
were actually needed like a shooting or
a fire
you know we saw they were basically
focused like jorge was saying earlier
entirely on the riots and so like over
the last year if you look all
at all the criminal data across the
country i mean that's effectively what's
been happening is the police are paying
attention to these
the civil unrest and and not paying
attention to the violent crimes that
actually really impact the communities
yeah well one thing too that is
interesting that i think we'll start to
figure out in these couple months is how
each city
major city deals with the potential
civil unrest
and and the communication they've used i
um in los angeles the los angeles county
sheriff alex villanova
he came out aggressive and said hey we
got national guard on standby
we got all this and stuff we are not
playing around compared last year
and according to some sources on the
ground i mean lapd so far as i know this
past week has been
handling the demonstrations pretty well
and i think
i think los angeles i mean i don't know
about every city but i know los angeles
has
they they for sure are going to fix the
mistakes they made last year because
their their county sheriff's a little
bit aggressive but
uh i i do definitely see what tim is
saying they need the police officers are
law enforcement
they need some type of support it needs
to come from somewhere in portland
uh i speak to a lot of officers they
feel like their work is useless because
they'll make the arrest they'll do all
this stuff but then the district
attorney will say
off the hook off the hook off the hook
and that's gonna bring morale down
um and i think in los angeles what we're
seeing is we're seeing an l.a county
sheriff say hey we're taking the
aggressive lane
we're ready to go we have national guard
on standby and and i know they
the the d.a down there george cascone is
not uh it's not a guy they like he's
super progressive but
even the l.a county sheriff is saying we
don't even care what the da's doing
we're going
bullhead you know all forces in and um
so far la hasn't seen
uh that that violence that we've seen in
other cities
what's the internet's definition of
insanity doing the same thing over and
over again expecting a different outcome
that was einstein yeah was it einstein i
think it was a meme so you got these
cops in portland who are like i'm going
to arrest this guy for breaking the law
and then they bring them to station and
the d.a goes you're free to go and they
go hey
i know i'll arrest him tomorrow for
breaking the law and the diego's you're
free to go
the woman who who set fi was accused of
setting fire to the police union
building
she was arrested last year on some
serious charges and they just cut her
loose drop the charges
then she comes back not even a year
later and burns down the police union
building
and then they released her without bail
at a certain point man
i don't i don't know what these cops
think they're doing it's like there's
this meme video where a guy
what else can they do though you know
please i mean but he got bill
they got bills to pay you know that's
not realistic for somebody who's your
house is burning down will you be like i
can't leave i'm homeless
i'll be homeless it's but it's like my
house is burning down but my family's
gonna starve if
we don't stay so you stay in a house
that's literally on fire you're
still getting a paycheck you know as
long as you're alive as long as what you
just said is very interesting what
you've said is
it's actually safer and easier for the
police to be
in the violent riots in a system that's
broken not working than it is to
actually leave and go somewhere
somewhere that would be more because
what what is a cops future employment in
this current climate
right now oh hey i just left the
portland pd uh you want to hire me
to be an nbc correspondent no no think
about that think about that that means
while minneapolis burns down it is
actually safer and more secure for an
officer
to be an ineffective and villainized
individual working for the department
than it is for them to move their family
to any other city for any other job
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you